thank you
okay so um
since this is a workshop i think i'm
going to do a slightly different talk
instead of
tell you what i know about i'm going to
tell you what i do not know
now just to say this is not a waste of
your time i hope what happens is the
audience will jump up and say hey that's
a trivial problem
or some of you
hopefully will think it's an interesting
problem at least so i'm going to present
two applications to you the first one is
called verbal fluency so i work with
psychologists and a verbal fluency task
is when
a psychologist would ask a human
participant to say as many animal words
for example as possible without
repeating in one minute so give it some
thought in your head like pretend you're
going to do this task
okay so
what kind of lists do humans produce
turns out
here's a random
example of six different participants
the list they produce in one minute
there are several things right one is
like they typically start from familiar
animals
and this is somehow
a semantic run by that i mean there
seems to be uh
sequences subsequences in there where
people tend to think about the same kind
of animals at least so
this hints at some markovian behavior
and the question is how do you model
this type of data
so the psychologists think of
this type of problem as
one where we retrieve words from memory
in this case
uh here's one picture of what might be
going on now this is way too small but
this is a abstract space of
animals
i forget about colors they don't mean
too much but let me zoom in a bit
okay so that's a small portion of the
graph
the idea is
somehow this is an embedding of
different animals
and things that's closer are
semantically related
okay
now let's consider one specific model to
uh to think about this problem so what
if i say that
um
let's treat this as if it's a random log
where i have
perpetually a graph with a vertex vertex
set v and those are just n different
animal words in english
furthermore let's assume there is
some unknown transition matrix p
which typically should be dense like we
believe people can think of any other
animal after one animal
all right and then
interestingly
because
the participants are instructed to not
repeat when they generate
the animal
lists
uh we assume the following um generative
story it's like here's this random walk
the participant is just doing a standard
random walk
and let xy x2 be the actual random walk
sequence however we do not observe that
sequence
instead
we only see a sensor expression
where
an animal shows up only when the first
time it is visited
so let's
think of
a for example let's say i have a very
special
graph and therefore standard
transition matrix
so let's say that's my graph it's a star
graph
i'm going to call this node one
two three four five up to say n here
okay
um
my x
one x two that
walk
could be
let's say i started from two
and i walk to one
uh then i may come back to two again
back to one
three one five one etc
okay we do not say that
okay instead
all we see is
two
one
and three
okay so that's our a sequence
now it's easy to see that uh if
we the random walk covers the hook rough
you will have n observations here and
it's just going to be a permutation of
your
uh and items
okay so that's all you see
in one list
the random tree
yes
okay
um
so what do we want to do we want to
estimate
the transition matrix
from such lists
so here's your problem right let's say
you have m different participants and
let's assume conveniently that all
humans share the same graph and
transition matrix in their hand
so you have m
lists and you want to estimate the
transition matrix from it
so how do we do that
um
well
the difficulty as
anyone can imagine is like
this conditional probability we already
know k different
animals and what is the probability of
hitting some new animal
that is a hidden sequence
the reason being let me say that this is
a k
from 1 2 to k k equals 2 here
and we're trying to decide what is the
chance that the animal number 3 shows up
right
if you only observe
sorry
this point
you don't know what's the actual walk
it could be
2 1
and 2 1 repeating any number of times
then jumping to three
right so you have essentially infinite
number of hidden sequences that you need
to integrate over
and
that is difficult to do if you just do
it straightforwardly
but
here's a different
idea and algorithm that one can think
about the problem
what if we say that
let's
call
um this
a big step an observed step
from the case animal to the k plus one
animal
now we can model this just this
particular step from k to k plus 1
as
an absorbing random walk of its own
so the idea would be you have your
original graph but whenever you visit an
animal
you mark it so let's say that's my
situation
at right here when ks2
okay
now i need to worry about the
probability
of my next destination was my k plus
once animal
i'm going to turn this graph at this
moment into an absorbing random walk
where
the nodes i have visited are
non-absorbing
and all the unvisited notes are
absorbing notes
so these guys would not be absorbing
and i'm going to start my random walk at
the case note in this case 1
i will try to compute
what's the probability that i get
absorbed in any one of those absorbing
state so
you can do this
as follows so think of the original
transition matrix p and by n
now let's reorder the nodes such that
a 1 2 to ak the nodes you have visited
you're going to put them first and then
the remaining are the nodes you have not
visited okay
so first reorder p and then turn it into
a
absorbing random walk by just you know
diagonalize this part and set this to
zero so you get this absorbing matrix
then it is known that the uh if you take
the fundamental matrix of this absorbing
random walk
i just compute that smaller matrix yeah
the inverse
and i j is going to be the expected
number of visits to j
before absorption
if you start from i
okay so that's well known and then you
just take one more step
uh you say that
that's the chance that uh if i start
from i what's the number of times i'm
going to visit j
if you further right multiply this with
the r matrix
that gives you the probability of you
being absorbed in any one of the uh
absorbing state okay so that's the
chance you will hit
a new
word
so you can compute
this
probability
in that way but keep in mind that here
you turned it into a specific observing
random walk
okay
then you can put everything together by
just multiplying this probability that's
going to get you your log likelihood the
difficulty here is
um since my
k is changing k is increasing every time
you get a slightly different
absorbing random walk
okay but you do this all together but at
least gives you a long likelihood
and
now
estimating the original transition
matrix p becomes a problem if you have a
likelihood let's just try maximum
likelihood turns out this is not convex
but
we just did a gradient method on that
just to have an estimate of p
okay
so
let me show you some empirical result
like how this way of estimating the
transition matrix worked
i'm going to show you three estimators
besides beside those the one i just
mentioned
let me present this p of rw random walk
it's just the standard like maximum
likelihood estimator on a random walk if
you pretend
the a sequence you observe are like just
come from a standard non-censored random
walk that's going to be wrong right
because it's going to say yeah you know
here there's a
transition from say from three to five
which is actually not the case in a star
graph
okay so we know that's wrong but that's
so easy to implement so we did it
nonetheless
another estimator
is to only take the first two items in
each list
and if you think about that in this
story that way is actually okay
okay
it's going to be
unbiased and so on so that's an okay one
but you're throwing away a lot of
information afterwards
okay so i'm going to show you uh
these three estimators on a different a
bunch of different
toy examples
so
i have this graph
with n equals 25 25 nodes
what i'm showing you on the x-axis is
m the number of
lists available to each estimator
okay so it starts from like 10 lists all
the way to maybe 600 lists
these lists are generated from from this
story okay
on the y-axis it's just the square
difference between your estimated
quantity and the true transition matrix
okay so
the red one is our estimator
and it goes down
now it's interesting to see that the the
rendezvous one as you would expect is
doing really poorly
for this star graph as expected because
it's mixing a lot of these types of
traditions
the first two
um
we
we believe it should just go down
eventually but because it's throwing
away a lot of information
it's not doing as good
here although initially somehow it's
it's better
so that's on a star graph
this is on the 2d grid
again undirected unweighted graph
transition is the standard one over
degree
this time we see that in the beginning
when you don't have a lot of data
actually
uh
using the wrong estimator isn't too bad
but eventually it gets
stuck there while the other two
estimators are going down
a random graph behaves
somewhat similarly
i think this one is interesting
if you have a ring graph instead
it turns out the wrong estimator was
doing quite well in the beginning
for a lot
longer
and the reason intuitively is because if
you have this ring graph
and you're doing this type of censored
output
what happens is um
intuitively you have
a situation that
after a while
you sort of cover an arc of the graph
and you run it back and forth
if you are here let's say this is k
the chance that you
are going to hit a new node you are
going to hit a new node either here or
here
okay but
that probability is
much smaller it's one over the uh
expectation it's one over the length of
the arc you already have it's one arrow
right so
so in this case actually um just the
knife estimate is getting it almost
right
okay
so we have some evidence that this
estimator sort of the red one seems to
be working
um but here comes the the questions
which we don't know anything about
like we don't know if this estimator is
consistent or not
if it is we also don't have any uh rate
on that
okay so that's
application number one
be happy to hear if you have thoughts on
how to think about this type of
estimators
okay
let me move on to
the second application
second application now is what i call
machine teaching
and this is
something
that if you're familiar with machine
learning it takes a while to get used to
so let me start with a very simple
example
of learning so we're not talking about
teaching yet we're just talking about
machine learning
so what i want to do here is i have a
one-dimensional uh
feature space so x is in one d let's say
this is between zero and one you just
have this interval
and there is a threshold function
unknown threshold function that you try
to estimate
so here's the assumption there is going
to be a second star between 0 and 1
such that
uh to the left of it we have this y
function which is minus one otherwise
it's uh plus one okay
you receive training data in the form of
an id random sample okay so let's assume
x is uniform so you just get a bunch of
uniform points let's say n samples
whose corresponding y is noiseless and
just come from this distribution
as a learner you have your hypothesis
space being you know
the collection of possible thresholds so
you know it's
it's this form you just don't know where
theta star is
okay so that's your problem right
the question to ask in machine learning
is of the following form
if
i give you end trending examples
okay how do you quantify like what is
your estimator and how do you quantify
uh the risk of your estimator
okay so let's think about it
if i have four
trending examples like that
then
one potential estimator
or way to or learning algorithm is to do
the following i'm just going to find
the the interval which is
content containing the innermost
black and white
points and i'm just going to put
my estimated decision boundary in the
middle
okay
now
the interesting question is um
how is this estimator going to work if
your future data is also draw id from
the same distribution
it's easy to see that like i'm being
really hand-wavy here but if you have
nid examples
roughly speaking
the length of this interval is going to
be 1 over n
and your
your estimator is in the middle of that
so you are going to be off
to the true estimator by a quantity
roughly speaking not far
not bigger than one over n so your error
is going to be one over f
did you get an x and y or just y in this
case you get both x and y during
training yes
in other words
if you want a future
error rate of less than epsilon
you need a
order one over epsilon
training examples
okay
probably okay
so that's standard motion learning
now i'm going to contrast this with
another
type of learning that we often do
in practice which is called active
learning
we said
in active learning
the learner has the ability to
ask queries so
initially there is no id sampled data
right the learner is going to say
i know the space is between 0 and 1
i have the ability to pick
any point x and ask
an oracle who knows the truth
for its label attacks
so that's all i can do but i'm going to
ask
one query at a time then i would
create an estimator maybe but in the
next iteration i will pick a different
query to ask and so on okay
if you think about our specific problem
the best strategy for the active learner
is essentially binary search you're
supposed to ask
the label
of a point in the middle
if it's white in our case here then what
we know is this side of the interval
cannot contain the decision boundary so
you cut out half of the hypothesis space
but your decision boundary can be
anywhere here so the next query you ask
is going to be the midpoint here
in this interval and so on and so forth
right so by doing so
this is exactly binary search uh in in
the interval
okay so let's ask the same question if i
want my final classifier to have an
error
at most epsilon how many queries do i
need to ask
and this is not hard to see that
you are much better off
oops sorry
it takes uh it's exponentially
smaller right you you just need this
number of queries okay so that's good
active learning people like it
okay the reason i'm introducing these
two learning paradigms is because i want
to introduce a third one
the third one is
strictly speaking not machine learning
instead it's machine teaching so let me
um
we say what that means
so let's assume that yeah we have a
learner that think of that supportive
activation would just find the midpoint
in your training set between the in the
most pair of
different label points
now let's say i'm the teacher i'm not
the learner i'm the teacher
i know what sata star is
okay
and i want to design the smallest
training set training set means x y
pairs okay
such that when i give my training set to
that specific learner it's going to
learn
a decision boundary very close to the
start
the question is how do i design such a
training set
so for this problem
just one d threshold function right
and let's assume the learner is the
support vector machine type of learner
it's clear that
one way that you can teach
is by using a training set like
this
just place two training examples
right next to the decision boundary but
on different side of it and let's say
they're epsilon
apart okay so clearly we
were able to get that learner
to a
decision boundary where that's epsilon
good
but you only need two examples
right it doesn't depend on n or absolute
now
okay
the reason
we
we just need a
two examples is because this is a
different setting we're no longer doing
learning okay we know what the
target is
and
we don't need to explore at all
okay so
that's okay
i hope everybody agree with me that's
one example like that
let me ask you a different question okay
so
what is participation
let's say
we have a different problem this time
it's not classification
instead it's density estimation
um
we have a quite a learner but this
learner takes a
point
cloud in rd
and it's just trying to estimate the
gaussian distribution from it
the estimator inside the learner is
fairly straightforward it's just your
standard sample mean sample covariance
okay so let's assume you have this
learner
but let me ask the teaching question
again suppose i'm a teacher
right and i want to convey to this
learner a particular gaussian
distribution in rd okay so with a mu
star and sigma star
all i can do is to somehow pick
a bunch of points and give it to the
learner i know the learner is going to
do this
if i want to use as
few
points as possible
how should i do it
so you're learning the moments you're
not learning learning the normal right
the fact that it's normal that doesn't
have anything to do with your problem
it's the it's the assumption it's the
assumption of the learner the learner is
just going to say uh
right okay sorry yeah the learner is
going to first say it's going to learn
accounting distribution
okay that's the motivation for that
particular learner
particularly then you're not going
through the points anything to do with
the the normal distribution
correct the the assumption here is that
learner is hard coded to only learn
content distributions
okay any suggestions
so for example
let's consider
1d
small d equals one right so let's say i
have this mu star here and i have some
particular
sigma star
how many
training examples do i need for this
type of thing
if i sample from this distribution
and i just saturate the learner with you
know infinite
examples the learner is going to learn
this eventually
but since we are the teacher we have the
freedom to design
to choose those points
we can do much better right
so in fact for this case um
convince yourself that yeah i mean just
again two points would be fine
so two points for 1d what about say a 2d
gaussian
or something like that
so let's say that's my target
why is that intuition about that
the trouble is what's the algorithm
right i mean the algorithm is right
there yeah that's the angle could be the
case that the third digit tells you
something in the fourth digit tells you
something else i mean
the algorithm is right here that's the
learner's average that's just like
a sample but that wasn't the case in the
other example it was not the case i
didn't specify it uh clearly it was
there was a learner assumption there
it's the no take 1d examples find the
midpoint
sorry
so in this case
you can show that in fact in general you
just need d plus one points just put
them like a tetrahedron type of
configuration and that particular
learner you can teach it
with d plus one examples
okay
so
let me see um
what are we doing here
we're we're actually solving the
following problem which is this picture
is some somewhat very similar to the the
one in the previous talk
the assumption is
we are the teacher we are faced with a
student this student
is a learning algorithm or an estimator
so this student is characterized
by
this a
where a maps
data space so that means that big d up
there is a particular training set
think of it this way
it maps a training set to
a parameter in the model space
right
and therefore if i'm doing teaching what
i want is i start with a teaching goal i
know what a model i want
i'm looking at the inverse mapping okay
this inverse mapping could be massive
depending on what your a is
and i'm going to pick among all these
possible training sets one that i like
the best so i need to define what i mean
by like the best
here's one possible way to do it
i'm saying that
what i want to do is to minimize over
training sets so if you are in the in
the machine learning setting this really
is a discrete object
it
it's like how many points you want in
your training set and what are they
but nonetheless i want to minimize the
cardinality of my set
okay that's what i mean by good training
set subject to that if i give this
training set to my student the student
is going to apply a
and arrive at the target that i want
okay so that's the general
idea of this
it turns out
this problem has been studied before
in a
computer theory where
this objective is known as the teaching
dimension
okay so it's a distinct but related
quantity to say basic dimension
smallest number of examples you will
need to exactly teach
a concept to a learner
okay
okay
so
now why is this problem interesting
besides like being a really interesting
theoretical problem
i claim that this is also something that
we can use to potentially
improve human education okay just think
of human student as your learner a
okay we of course need to assume a
certain computational model of the
student hey
but if that's the case
if we have a way to formulate
what our teaching goal is then we can
use this to essentially come up with the
best lesson
okay now of course here best is defined
as the shortest lesson in some way but
you can imagine uh generalizing both
this here and relaxing this equality so
the idea is
maybe
you don't want to teach exactly that
model you just want to say okay close
enough is fine
and then here instead of just the size
of the
training set you can put some form of
teaching effort on different training
items like you may want to teach using
simple examples for example
okay
so
what i can tell you is
this idea actually works
we worked with psychologists and we did
so
not education in classroom setting yet
but we did something in cognitive
science where we teach people to do
categorization
in a 1d stimuli space so this is the
typical psychological experiment that
you see people do basically
we have a bunch of line segments
displayed on the computer screen and the
human participant we need to teach them
which ones are called short which ones
are called long okay so as you can
imagine it's the 1d threshold
classification problem right
and they receive a trending set of
and different line segments each with a
correct label and then they need to
learn from that and predict on future
line segments randomly draw from
different lengths
okay
i'm not going to go into the details but
just to tell you that on that type of
problem
uh psychologists have
accumulated a whole bunch of
different computational models of human
a they have different assumptions of
what a the algorithm is for a human
being
we took one
commonly used a model and we used the
the teaching framework to actually
design a training set
and compare it with this randomly
selected uh training set
trending on uh humans and yes humans do
generalize
better using this training set so
not too surprising except that it's uh
actually on humans and super noisy but
interesting to see it work
okay so
let me bring it back to the question
here that
related to the workshop
what if
we want to teach
over a graph
so why do we want to do that maybe there
are conceptual graphs in human's mind
for example remember the animal
graph
and labeling on this graph could map to
how people think about different animals
for example if we
tell a child like a snake
is poisonous
okay
but i uh let's say a cow is not
poisonous right
they this is essentially like you put
seed labels on some of the notes
and they're going to form opinions
okay
now
some of the
graph-based diffusion algorithms can be
used
as a hypothetical cognitive model
in terms of how they diffuse that
information okay
so here's the setup let's say we have a
graph
on directed
and let's say we have a target labeling
y star so this y star is a
fixed and given labeling of each and
every node
on that graph so that's our teaching
goal
furthermore we need a model of the
student
now for this group let's just say it's
mink cut so the idea is
if
i give you a set of seed
nodes on the undergraph with sleeve
labels say binary
and you do a mean cut on the graph from
that seed set you will arrive at
essentially a
cut or a complete labeling of the whole
graph
that's here so y star s is the seed
labeling on the small set s
and a is this diffusion algorithm or
label completion algorithm on graph we
want this diffusion to eventually arrive
at our goal y star right
but how do we choose
the initial
set for example so that it's as small as
possible
and of course this is the inverse
problem of graph-based semi-supervised
learning
let me show you one example here
we use the particular
diffusion algorithm
not mean cut just because it's somewhat
easier to compute it as a closed form
the way i uh
okay so yeah this is a four by four grid
so just four by four red
is it connected
um
what i'm plotting here is each pixel is
really
a
node in the graph
and i have
let's start from this ignore the green
regions i have
four
seed nodes two are blue two are red okay
those are the two different classes
starting on this graph
i do the diffusion
and
this is the result i basically cut the
graph in this form right so i have this
now let's
think about the inverse problem
if that's the case
if i assume this is the
eventual goal i want
is there
a smaller
seed set
such that if i give it to the same
diffusion algorithm
will result in the same classification
here
so that's the problem
and
we actually did it by
brute force
and on this very small example as you
can imagine i can just enumerate all two
to the six things uh different initial
sets
and see
and give it to it and see what happens
it turns out you have many many
solutions and i'm just plotting here a
histogram
of uh solutions so what what we have
here is this x-axis is the size of your
initial set and these sets
are all succeeded in producing the final
the same target classification
so you have a whole bunch of them
okay
what's interesting is um this this guy
here that's the smallest solution turns
out you have two solutions two initial
training sets of size three that's the
smallest you can go for this particular
example
and they look as follows
remember that's the target
classification
that's one initial seed set
it just happens to be two right here and
one blue there again ignore the ring
here is another one
okay so
these are the two
okay
now
the question is which we have no answer
yet
yes
can we say anything about
the smallest size
with respect to
some spectral property of the graph
and there's of course an algorithmic
question how do you actually find the
smallest as
so
i'll be happy to hear from the audience
and that's all thank you
question
it looks like you might have to
especially in the human
so teaching humans for example to
accomplish a task it seems like you
would have to learn the learner yes
so in fact that's very true
um it really says like for humans you
need to learn what they're essentially a
is
yes
and that's an empirical question and you
can imagine we run uh human experiments
by giving them partially labeled graph
let them finish right and try to maybe
fit it against one of the
algorithmic
procedures that is indeed true and here
i'm just abstracting it and just pretend
that we have one of the averages
here okay